yeah so my name is alec so this talk is
about uh how to unify data
pre-processing and training in machine
learning pipelines uh using a new
project we've created called raid data
sets
so um i'm alex i'm a software engineer
at uh any scale and also a maintainer on
the ray project
and clark who i'm not sure if he
uh if we figured out the technical
difficulties yet uh is also very similar
to me he's also a software engineer at
any scale
and also works on ray
um
so yeah let's get started so uh just a
brief overview of what we're gonna talk
about today so um
the first thing we're going to talk
about is essentially the state of how ml
training and scoring pipelines in the
real world look today and the types of
challenges that they face and hopefully
that'll give uh you all some idea of the
types of things that the types of
problems that we're aiming to solve and
then we'll go ahead and talk about ray
datasets which is sort of our solution
of these problems
and we'll see how it leverages rey to uh
you know provide a really clean uh easy
to use in performance solution and then
finally clark is going to finish finish
us off by taking a look at a couple of
use cases for ray data sets and how some
of our early production users are using
data sets in production already
all right
so let's get started so yeah so if we
take a look at how uh ml pipelines for
you know just the pre-processing to
training part tend to work today
is people tend to usually start by
pre-processing their data using some
sort of existing uh
data processing framework in a lot of
cases that's something like spark or pi
spark um or if you're really in the
python eco system maybe you're using
something like task
so now this is typically where you sort
of hit the first uh bump in the road in
terms of getting to uh in terms of doing
distributed training on your data later
is you have to find some way of like
connecting your pre-processing to your
training
and the typical approach that we've seen
people use in production has been to
take all of your pre-processed data
and then write that to some kind of a
distributed storage system like hdss or
s3
um and then usually you'll you know
you'll have to like convert this data
into like a parquet format or something
like that and then you'll launch a
completely new job maybe it's even in a
different language um and read all that
data in from your storage
and then maybe perform some last second
operations on it and then finally train
on that data
so as you can see there's like you need
to stitch together multiple different
systems that don't always work perfectly
together
in order to do this
um and so typically this involves
including a new system another system
something like kubeflow um or airflow
that's designed specifically for the
purpose of like orchestrating your ml
pipelines so something like kubeflow is
really built specifically for um machine
learning i think
and if you have something even more
complicated like a more complicated
pipeline you may need something like
airflow like a general purpose workflow
engine
to help you manage all these
dependencies in scheduling
all right so now let's take a closer
look at the challenges that the current
systems in the wild face today so
there are a lot of performance overheads
associated with how people are doing
their um building their ml pipelines
today if you're using something like
spark or something that's really based
off of the java ecosystem
a lot of users tend to find that they
actually spend most of their cpu time in
their job just serializing and
deserializing their data
not doing the actual like useful compute
work that they want to do
if you're using a system
if you're using um other systems in the
python ecosystem because of the you know
global interpreter lock you typically
need multiple processes and you'll find
that you spend a lot of your time again
on overhead of just copying around the
same data between different processes to
actually parallelize your your
operations
and finally there's this giant overhead
here where we wrote all of our data to a
storage system and we didn't really need
to do that right when we think about the
pipeline we think we want to do
pre-processing and then feed the data
into training
there was no
there's usually no hard requirement to
actually be writing the state of the
storage which is a very expensive
operation since you're changing the
format you need to write it to a disk um
etc
um and then there's also a lot of like
implementation and operational
complexity i think uh with with these
pipelines so you might have multiple
languages um you these different types
of pre-processing versus training
operations tend to be completely
different workloads that require
different types of scheduling and
different types of optimization
and they use different types of
resources so pre-processing is typically
done on large cpu clusters whereas for
training especially in the deep learning
world we typically want to use gpus
and then finally there are a lot of
operations that people in the machine
learning and research communities really
like and want to be able to use but the
current distributed systems out there
for doing uh you know machine learning
in production don't support so one
really big one here is per epoch
shuffling you know anytime you're doing
something with deep learning it's really
nice to be able to shuffle your data
every epoch to increase your model's
accuracy but there's no really good way
of doing that once you scale to multiple
machines today
all right so now we're going to talk a
little bit about ray data sets and uh
hopefully you'll see how ray data sets
solves a lot of these problems
so before we jump into it we're going to
take a quick look at ray so i don't want
to focus too much on on rey in this talk
but i do think it's worth mentioning
some of the really important properties
of ray that led us to build data sets on
top of it
because we we can really leverage ray to
do a lot of the heavy lifting to solve
some of those problems
so one of the most important things um
that ray provides us here is a really
efficient data layer so ray is largely
implemented in c plus and so
it's able to sort of bypass a lot of the
issues that python processes typically
have by using shared memory um to share
memory between different processes on
the same machine which allows us to
avoid doing a lot of copying
um
uh ray also is really well integrated
with arrow and so we're able to do
things like zero copy reads that avoid
having to deserialize your data um once
you read it into your process
you can just use that exact same
representation that you already had
stored in your object store
um ray also comes with locality aware
scheduling so if you have a large amount
of data you don't want to transfer it
around your cluster all the time
and so ray will try to make intelligent
scheduling decisions to uh do that and
then finally if you do really need to
move your data around the cluster this
is where you run into a lot of
distributed systems challenges usually
uh with overloading nodes and things
like that and ray comes with built-in
you know the object transfer protocols
are really built to handle these really
really stressful edge cases
and then the other really good benefit
of array here is that it's really
general purpose so it has a
[Music]
resource-based scheduler allow
allows you to specify the type of
resource that you want to give to
different types of types of tasks within
a single cluster and so this allows you
to do some things with cpus and other
things with gpus uh very seamlessly and
easily it's also extremely robust
and highly scalable so it can run
different types of workloads you can
even run an entire spark cluster on top
of your array cluster with very little
overhead
and uh it's very because it's very easy
to build distributed systems in rey
it really lets you access a wider
ecosystem of other libraries on top of
raid 2.
all right so now let's take a concrete
look at what ray datasets is so
fundamentally ray datasets provides
essentially a distributed table
abstraction
um
so this is very similar this
architecturally may seem very similar to
um frameworks you've already seen like
data frames like pi sparks data frame
for example um but we'll quickly go into
what makes them different but first i
want to talk about sort of what rate
data sets are designed to use so the
first and most important thing for ray
data sets is that it's meant to be an
easy way for you to get your data from
wherever you were doing a lot of your
heavy lifting etl type jobs
into array cluster whether that data is
coming directly from something like
spark or whether that data is coming
from something like s3 already like a
storage system
um we also want you to be able to do
some amount of pre-processing on that
data there's always these types of last
second like last mile pre-processing
operations that you may want to do
um right before you go into training
mode that it doesn't make sense to do
before
in earlier stages of your pre-processing
and then finally there are some types of
operations that you want to perform on
your data that require using a bunch of
different resources and these are things
where ray really shines and so we want
to enable you to do those types of
operations using a higher level api
using data sets
all right
so before we take a closer look uh one
thing i want to sort of emphasize here
is that ray datasets is not meant to be
a general purpose data frame library so
the sort of the place that we see data
sets uh fitting into the ecosystem if we
wanted to work in we want to make sure
it works well with the other data frame
libraries
so
um data sets in spark for example are
not meant to be the same thing what we
sort of envision you doing is if you
have a really large scale you know etl
job for uh getting your data into a
format to do
machine learning on we expect that
you'll still continue to use spark or
flink or whatever other um
whatever whatever other systems you're
using for etl
um and then use gray data datasets as
sort of that last thing that lets you
feed all that like data analytics um
type of you know formatted data into um
like a format that's usable for training
all right
so to take a closer look at this um how
we envision sort of or how we see ray
being used as a data loader is you
essentially start with your data in some
other format outside of your ray cluster
maybe that's hdfs or s3 maybe that's uh
existing data frame already
and we want rave data set to be sort of
this like
universal thing like a compatibility
layer that you pass it into
um and then we want to make sure that
all of the ml training libraries you use
are also compatible with data sets and
so
you may find today that it's very hard
for example to take something like spark
and pass the output of a large spark job
into something like tensorflow
um and so ray datasets is sort of
supposed to be um supposed to make that
possible and easy right so if you can
convert all of your etl data frames into
a ray data set you can do any last
second operations you need and then feed
that directly into your training
framework
and the way we really accomplish this
and are able to support so many things
quickly is by really leveraging arrow so
you know this may have all sounded
familiar to you because a lot of what
we've talked about is what arrow really
solves on a single node
and so data sets is meant to essentially
take what
play that role that error plays on a
single
machine and uh sort of provide you with
that same benefit in a distributed
setting
all right so um
here we can like take a quick look at
sort of some of the formats that we
already support for um four-way data
sets so as you can see you can use
whatever file formats you're typically
comfortable with or read things in
directly from other data frames um if
this diagram is a little hard to read i
would encourage you to check out the ray
datasets uh documentation which contains
these figures
um and we'll have a link to that at the
end of this talk
right cool
um yeah and so um you know it's not just
important to support these types of
operations we want to make sure we can
do them efficiently and easily so the
api that we want you to be able to use
should be as simple as just read parquet
or read csv
the exact type of thing you would be
used to using in arrow or panda
um
and we also want to make sure that you
can literally still convert to and from
pandas
um and you know like again you should
also be able to
write things out to storage just as
easily as you read them in
um
and again so we really leverage arrow
here and so that allows us to get really
really high performance on all of our
nodes and ray lets us parallelize this
easily and so you know even in
production already we've seen companies
like amazon that are using data sets for
um
ingesting large amounts of data and
we've seen that you know the
sort of performance we see um from arrow
on single threads we're able to scale
that up close to linearly to jobs that
are in the petabyte or tens of petabyte
range
all right cool so let's take a quick
look at some of the last mile
pre-processing operations that we
support um so
these are in a lot of ways some of the
operations that you would expect out of
most other libraries that you use for
pre-processing so you can do things like
mapping batching filtering you can do
some aggregations on your data
um and we also support some shuffle
operations which if you come from more
of a systems background you'll recognize
these as sort of the notoriously hard
operations that require a lot of
communication
um if you come from a machine learning
background these are what sort of the
operations that you just sort of expect
to have
and may be missing sometimes when you
use other systems
um so this is sort of just an example of
what data may look like as it passes
through your system so if you start with
some input you may want to do some
mapping on it
and then you want you might want to
shuffle that data around between your
different nodes so that all the data
that all the data ends up in the right
place before you reduce that data or do
something like training on that data
and then finally we'll aggregate that
output together maybe that's the output
of your model
all right
um and so yeah there's also a bunch of
other optimizations that we've built
into data sets um so for example we
support pipelining um and so pipelining
if you're unfamiliar with the concept is
a way of making sure that when we have
these really expensive clusters up we're
making the best use out of them
so if you imagine a typical pipeline um
you may have a loading step where you
load your data in you might want to do
some pre-processing and then you might
want to do some inference or score your
data
and if we naively did that
serially we would find that we would
start by loading our data and then we'd
pre-process then we do inference but
before the inference step started we
just had a bunch of gpus that we're
probably already paying for that are
sitting there idle doing nothing
and so the idea with pipelining is that
it would be great if once we loaded our
first bit of data we're able to begin to
do pre-processing on that immediately
and then being and do inference on that
immediately so we begin to use our gpu a
lot sooner and while we're using the gpu
we want to also be loading other data
and pre-processing other data in
parallel
and ray essentially lets you do this
with a single line of code
another really important uh
concept that we support is windowing and
so windowing essentially
is best described as you can imagine
what would happen if you tried to pass
your entire data through a pipeline at
once
you'll find that you need to be able to
store you know all your data and a lot
of your intermediate results
in your cluster at a single time
so this data is really really large you
either need a massive potentially
infeasibly large cluster or you might
have to take a performance hit by
spilling the disk
and so windowing is a concept where we
can break our data set up into chunks
that all fit in our cluster
and then pass our pass each window in
one at a time through our pipeline
and this will allow us to keep
everything in memory um to keep
everything really efficient while uh not
having to spill to disk
right cool so now i'm going to pass it
on to clark who's going to talk a little
bit about the different use cases that
people have with ml datasets and take a
look at a couple of real world examples
of how people are using it today
thanks alex first awesome first half of
the talk um my name is clark i'm on
alex's team and i focus on a lot of like
data plane stuff and i've been working
on data sets a lot recently so the two
big use cases that we want to talk about
that data sets really excels at is
scalable shuffled ml ingest and
efficient batch inference
scalable shuffled ml ingest first if
you're not familiar a little bit of
background
what exactly do we mean by ml ingest
fundamentally this is just loading data
into one or more model trainers
which on a single node can be pretty
simple but once you go into distributed
setting things get a little bit more
complex but first a quick little
overview of uh what exactly is involved
in ml ingests
uh typically you're going to be loading
the data from storage
you're then going to want to partition
the data into a shard per trainer if
you're doing distributed training
you're going to want to batch the data
into gpu batches
and then you're going to want to shuffle
the data before each epoch
and this is typically done using a local
shuffling where you only shuffle within
a trainer shard before each epoch
that's the most popular option
primarily because global shuffling uh
before each epoch is
more difficult but it actually ends up
being much better in order to achieve
like optimal model accuracy within a set
number of epochs and actually i'm going
to do a quick little aside on that uh
first for those that aren't familiar why
shuffle before an epoch like if we just
shuffle globally once before it's
training why isn't that fine
the tldr for this is that for certain
models uh epoch shuffling gives you much
better model accuracy
after a set number of epochs within a
given training window um and that's
often a common constraint of to users
that we've talked to where they have for
example a 12-hour window where they want
to train
as many epochs as possible so they care
about high training throughput and they
want to get as much precision gain
uh on uh each epoch
and
fundamentally if you want to know why
this is the case shuffling before each
epoch it decorates samples within and
across batches
um and uh in this case yeah we're doing
this before each epoch it reduces
variance it improves the generalization
of the model and it prevents uh it
prevents that pesky overfitting that we
all super hate when training our models
um and i i would go into a little more
detail but i think i'm really short on
time uh but fundamentally uh there are a
few papers out there that have examined
this um i
definitely would recommend uh one a
convergence and analysis of uh
stochastic gradient descent under
shuffling super great paper
um but generally results in an improved
statistical gain uh
for each step in the training process if
you shuffle before each epoch
um so first
why exactly is this even a problem you
know aren't you just loading data into
your trainers like why
isn't this just simple ingest why is
this tough uh well first at a certain
data and cluster scale you need
parallelized scalable reading from
storage if you did it all serially with
a single thread
um your trainers would be super unhappy
because they'd be waiting forever
um and then you also need to uh
you need to try to not waste your idle
uh you you don't want to you don't want
your gpus to be idle while you're
reading and shuffling data as alex
talked about uh just because your gpu is
idle uh doesn't mean that you're not
paying for it
uh you're almost always paying for that
gpu that's just sitting there um so for
example here
uh this is a situation where a trainer
is waiting for data to be
loaded and shuffled before training on
each epoch and as you can see we have
all these gaps where the gpu is sitting
idle um so that's all time uh those are
all times when you're paying for a gpu
but it's not actually being used
and then also a few other things that
make this hard well first we have to
keep the api simple despite the fact
that we're now talking about
large-scale data
and we're also talking about large
clusters and distributed training we
still want the api to be as simple as
possible
um also the full pipeline may not fit in
memory as alex just talked about
when talking about windowing um your
entire working set for your ingestion
pipeline especially when you're doing
shuffling which will create intermediate
copies of your data set might not all
fit in your cluster's memory
local shuffles they hurt model accuracy
as we talked about before
compared to a fully global shuffle
but global pre-puck shuffling uh in a
distributed setting is fundamentally
pretty difficult because of this like
all to all communication uh basically
there's between the mappers and reducers
in a shuffle there is a ton of data
interchange and this can result in a lot
of uh transferring of data uh over the
network
which is not fun
so how does a dataset solve this well
first
as uh alex hinted at our i o layer is
super scalable uh very easy to
parallelize reading from like high
bandwidth storage solutions like s3 and
hdfs for example that's all you have to
do right there
to launch 20 parallel reading tasks from
s3 it's a very simple api but a very
powerful io layer under the hood
um and just to give you an idea of what
this would look like
three parallel read tasks from s3 you
can feed your data to the trainers
pretty quickly
um also like how exactly do we keep the
gpu from sitting up idle how do we keep
the gpu saturated uh with data sets we
use the pipelining of the pre-processing
and shuffling stages with training
and uh instead of having these like
little gaps of gpu idle time you will
instead see that by pipelining the
shuffle data loading stage with the
model training stage we are able to
limit that gpu idle time just to pretty
much the first epoch after that first
epoch uh since we're concurrently uh
loading and shuffling the data uh for
the next epoch while training on the
kearney epoch uh you'll see that uh the
trainers never really have to wait for
the data loading and shuffling to finish
and as long as your shuffle data loading
throughput is uh is more than your
training throughput
then uh basically after the first epoch
the trainer should only see hot shuffle
data um and then per epoch shuffling
it's a difficult distributed problem how
do we do it efficiently well as alex
talked about our great distributed in
memory object store allows us to do
super efficient transfers and also zero
copy reads for workers that are on the
same node it allows us to do these
shuffle operations the map and reduce
stages very quickly
we also have locality replacement of
shuffle shards onto trainers uh and
that's as simple in this api example uh
where we give these locality hints where
we say like hey these are all of the
trainers
do your best when splitting the data set
into shards for uh one shard for each
trainer do your best to co-locate those
on the same node um so you don't have to
transfer data over to the network so
it's just small
optimizations like that that can make a
huge difference uh in like your actual
shuffled data loading throughput
which of course affects your training
throughput and so here is an example
there of
what this
this little uh workflow translates to
in terms of the pipelining uh the repeat
of the random shuffle on each epoch and
the eventual split of the shards to the
training workers
and then as alex also talked about um we
use windowing in order to limit the
working set size
for uh for a shuffled ingestion pipeline
and this prevents us from running out of
cluster memory and prevents us from
spilling through the disk so as you can
see here we're only
doing our shuffle data loading on one
window at a time
um so despite us dividing the data set
in the three windows here and limiting
the size of that intermediate data set
that's in the cluster just at one time
this is all still just one epoch
here you are trading off shuffle quality
with cluster size
by windowing you can have a smaller
cluster since the working set size is
smaller but you're going to no longer be
shuffling on the entire global data set
at once you're only shuffling on smaller
windows so your shuffle quality takes a
little bit of a hit
and uh this we also keep the api very
simple i'm gonna go through this a
little bit quickly since we're limited
on time the trainer api here is just
like a simple task that consumes a shard
um and then trains on gpu batches
and this is what you would probably have
right here this code example for a
ingestion pipeline on small data and
when training on a single node um so
relatively simple you basically read
parque you repeat for the number of
epochs that you want you should make
sure that each window is shuffled and
then you feed that data set to the
trainer for it to consume and train on
to extend this to a large data scale and
a multi-node distributed training
setting this is really all that's
required right here
you window to constrain the working set
size and you split the data into shards
and feed those uh to trainers
um so case studies uh first a little bit
of background common problem here is
like the existing solution as a
bottleneck in their training pipeline um
so this is where shuffled data loading
is really the issue why they're not
training as fast as they want and then
also the models are shuffle sensitive
where the shuffle quality does in fact
affect model accuracy
we have two case studies here a
high-tech ml platform that's a startup
that's currently in stealth mode their
old solution was actually writing data
to s3 and then using petastorm to load
it into horabad
for those that don't know pedostorm is
an ingest library from uber
our solution that we pitched was porting
the pandas uh
to s3 uh portion of the pipeline to das
unrave preprocessing and then feeding
that directly to raid data sets for
ingestion into the horva trainers
and then the other case study was a
large tech company in transport space
that was originally loading data from s3
again using petastorm and we actually
said continue loading data from s3 but
this time use data sets uh both case
studies suffered from the above common
problems by the way like both of these
have the same issues
um so uh for benchmark results uh very
quick summary uh ray uh desk and raiden
datasets was eight times faster than the
old solution on a popular new york city
taxi data set and also uh for the other
case study of where we're still loading
from s3 uh we were four times faster
and this is by the way uh when we're
doing more work because we're doing a
global shuffle instead of a local
shuffle so you're getting a higher
quality shuffle and better performance
even at small scales
and then we're also working on more
comprehensive benchmarks that are in
progress
um the other use case i'll go over very
quickly is batch inference where you do
some pre-processing and then you perform
model inference over uh batches of data
and save the results
um so there are a few issues here there
are some scheduling issues you don't
want to transfer the data around the
cluster and you want to reserve gps for
a fraction of the time and you need to
keep the gpu saturated as we talked
about before
um we saw the scheduling issue with
raise grade scheduling properties
automatic data locality and raised
resource scheduling
and uh we use pipelining to solve the
issue of idle gpus
and the
case studies we have a startup that's
processing drone imagery and a high-tech
ml platform that's uh got an existing
solution uh just using pandas to torch
and the results
uh just to skip through it we're five
times faster on this data set for batch
entrance
um as you can see from these graphs here
and so we provide more resource
efficiency and better performance even
at small data scales
uh so in summary existing ml platforms
our ml pipelines suffer from a lot of
issues and raid data sets
we hit that mark
using uh hyperscale implementations of
ml operations like shuffled um we keep
the api simple and for mlm.js and batch
inference we
beat the existing competition by a lot
in terms of performance
so yeah i had to go through the end
there pretty quickly but uh yeah thank
you for listening to the talk and then
uh we're probably a little bit out of
time for questions but please hit us up
on our discussion forum uh check us out
online and uh we're hiring so if these
problems are interesting you please come
check us out